[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARISHMA SHAH: All right.
Hi, everyone.
I'm honored to be here with you.
And as you know, tech
overlays all industries.
Because of the
attendees here today,
the diversity of the lineup,
we already know that.
And one of my
favorite quotes is,
"When you see a glimmer of
madness in people's eyes
when they speak about what
they do, pull up a chair
and let them transport
you to their world."
And we're about to be
transported to four worlds
through these
phenomenal women today,
and we're going to
kick off with that.
So we'll just go down the line.
Tell us about your world
and what drives you.
HILLARY HARTLEY: Hi,
I'm Hillary Hartley.
I live in San Francisco,
but I sort of commute
to DC a little bit.
I am a federal employee.
Hello, bureaucrat.
And honestly anyone that would
like to be a bureaucrat, this
is a great time.
Your government
needs you, especially
if you're a technologist.
So I'll be back there,
just a little plug.
But what has driven me has been
a combination of my family,
both my parents and
now my nuclear family,
and also just I was hooked.
Really my first
job out of college
was with the team that
runs arkansas.gov, so
the state website for Arkansas.
And it was late 90's.
We were putting services on
the web for the first time.
Possibilities kind
of seemed endless
in terms of what we could
do to make your life easier,
or your life easier,
and my life easier
in terms of interacting with the
government, and I was hooked.
So I've been kind of
an outsider, not really
a govie, about 20 years.
But I have been serving
the federal government
for the last four years.
And I can't see myself
really doing anything else.
But five years
ago I sort of took
a sideways journey with
some friends in the Bay Area
who we've been going to South
by Southwest for several years
and weren't quite getting
the same thing out
of that conference
anymore, but we still
longed for that community.
So we thought, well, can we
convince a bunch of people
to just go somewhere with
us and have a sort of South
by Southwest, Burning
Man-type experience.
And so we ended up
looking into renting out
a hotel in Palm Springs.
And doing the math on exactly
like how many tickets will we
need to sell to be
able to do this.
So we thought,
OK, if we can sell
400 tickets we can
buy out this hotel
and have all our friends
come to the desert
and it will be amazing.
And we did it.
It sold out in 48
hours, and now we're
doing it for the fifth
year this summer.
And someone coined
it Burning TED,
which is probably accurate.
It's a pool party, but with
people like yourselves.
With amazing, creative,
entrepreneurial, not just
technologists, but
really a wide spread
of folks that have
found this community.
So that's Yes and Yes Yes.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: Wow
that's pretty amazing.
Can I get a ticket
for this year?
HILLARY HARTLEY:
Yes, they're on sale.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: Hi, my
name is Aniyia Williams,
and I'm the founder
and CEO of TINSEL.
We make tech jewelry for
women, and this is really
driven by a couple of things.
My personal passion
for creating things.
I have a lot of hobbies.
Actually I should say I used
to have a lot of hobbies
because I don't really
have a lot of time to do
but so many things today.
And it really also was
spurn out of the fact
that I've noticed that
consumer electronics are not
designed with women in
mind, and we deserve better.
I'm actually wearing
our product right now.
It's a necklace that actually
has fully integrated headphones
in it, so.
DIANA TRUJILLO: Hi, everyone.
My name is Diana Trujillo, and
I immigrated from South America.
And right now my job
is to explore space.
My job is to try to figure
out, with an international team
of scientists and engineers, if
there was ever any possibility
of life on the surface of Mars.
And I love my job.
My job as a Deputy
Project System Engineer
and as a Deputy Team Chief
for the Engineering division
means that I am in charge of
the technical integrity of what
we do with the Mars
Curiosity Rover.
The Mars Curiosity Rover
is the biggest robot
that we have landed on
the surface of Mars.
He has laser beam
eyes, nuclear power.
It's like you're thinking
about Marvel or something
and we just actually landed
this ginormous thing.
I love it.
I love my job
because every day I'm
part of the few people that
actually get to see pictures
from a different world, right?
I'm among the first 20 people
to see an image that is just
getting transmitted from Mars.
And I think that I just
love the fact that space
is such a romantic area because
you think about the fact
that you're trying to discover,
not as special individual that
was a genius and somehow made it
to work in the tech industry is
actually as humanity.
You're trying to find
out what's out there.
You're trying to understand
things that nobody actually
understands.
And I think that it requires
a lot of different backgrounds
and it requires a lot of
different ways of thinking
because nobody has seen it.
There so many times at work
that I see the picture of Mars
and I'm like, I did
not expect the Rover
to get stuck like that.
Or I didn't expect the arm to
move the rock that we touch.
We were sure that rock
was ginormous plate,
and it turned out to be
actually not that big.
And so, yeah.
So that's kind of
what I do right now.
KARISHMA SHAH: Thank you.
Kim?
KIM HUNTER: Thanks for
having me here today.
My name is Kim Hunter, and I
had some similar experiences
in Washington.
I was in DC for 10 years.
I went there to
change the world.
I felt like politics
was the way to do it.
I started to see some breakdowns
in how to make change,
so went and traveled
the developing world.
Found social entrepreneurship
and individuals
that were really building
businesses and thinking
how to solve big problems.
Landed in San Francisco
four years ago.
Started to work with
impact-driven startups
and met Aclima.
And so Aclima is
actually an Earth shot.
It's basically, how can
we explore the world
that we live in today and really
turn the signals of the Earth
into data that we can use?
So we deploy environmental
and sensor networks that
map air quality in real-time.
We do that in buildings.
There's actually an Aclima node
in the back of the room here.
We're deployed across
Google's portfolio.
We also map the
outdoor environment.
So the idea is we can provide
hyper-local, high-resolution
data about air occlusion
and air quality,
so that we can better
represent the environment
and have a healthier
people and planet.
And then I'm also really
passionate about women's
leadership.
Two years ago I started Women
Catalysts with Lindsay Jean
Thompson, who is here today.
And we really wanted
to create a community
to support women to take action.
To ask for help.
To give help.
And we just celebrated our
two year anniversary and over
a $35,000 raise for local
nonprofits this year.
KARISHMA SHAH: Amazing.
When I spoke to Kim earlier to
prep for this panel she said,
my work makes my soul sing.
And I thought that was just a
phrase to share with you all.
To find work that
makes your soul sing.
So I'm going to ask the question
that's on everyone's mind now.
Deana, how do you get
to work on something
literally out of this world?
Had you always wanted
to work for NASA?
DIANA TRUJILLO: I have.
So, yeah, my story is
a little bit unusual.
So I'm originally from South
America and I came to the US
when I was 17 by myself.
I only had $300 in my pocket.
I didn't know any English.
I didn't know anyone, but
I had this crazy dream
that I wanted to work in
space and explore the unknown.
But that dream kind
of collided with what
the dream of every
Hispanic, my people.
My Hispanic people's
dream is to come to the US
and hopefully be a maid.
And hopefully get
enough money as a maid
to send back to your country
and take care of your own.
So those two things that
clash in my mind I still
managed to somehow
become a maid,
and take care of somebody else's
house, and get enough money.
But it still felt like
there's something missing.
I feel like I'm meant
to do something else.
And that feeling of
being uncomfortable,
that feeling that maybe a
lot of you guys feel of I
am meant to do something
else with my life,
was what pushed me
to get two more jobs
and then put myself
through English classes.
And after that go to
university and get a degree
on Aerospace Engineering.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
I think that after that I had
my first break, which was I
was doing great at school,
and just side note.
I was doing great at
school and in Colombia they
grade you with numbers.
But it's like, you're doing
great, you're 90 or 100.
And I kept looking at my
transcripts and I'm like 4.0?
This is terrible.
My dad is going to kill.
He's not going to
understand what's going on.
And I didn't understand until
I walked into somebody's office
and they're like, no, you should
apply for the Honor's Society.
I was like.
OK.
And at that point was when
everything make sense to me.
I had not realized that I
was doing so great in school.
And somebody gave me
a break and the break
that I got was somebody
said, hey, go to this website
and apply for this internship.
It was a NASA
Academy internship.
And so the NASA
Academy is a program
that around like 3,000 people
apply, 18 people gets elected.
And the program is
super, super competitive
because what they do is
that once you get selected,
they fly you to every
single NASA center
to meet the center directors.
They fly you to places
where you meet the CEO.
You meet astronauts.
And I don't know what
happened, but they selected me,
and I was the first Hispanic
woman on that group.
[APPLAUSE]
And so yes, so I
got to meet everyone
that had the job that I wanted.
And in fact, I went
from not having
the option of understanding
what I could do with my life
to thinking that I
wanted everyone's job.
I want that job
today and tomorrow.
And it's like, OK, I
don't know what job,
but I want all of them.
KARISHMA SHAH: I feel like
you have enough energy
to take everyone's job.
DIANA TRUJILLO: So, anyways.
What ends up happening
with that is I
met everyone, but here's one
thing that was interesting.
Nobody looked like me.
There were all men.
There were all white men.
There was no Latina
or Latino in it.
Not even that, right?
And they were all 50 and 60.
And they were like, one
day, you'll get there.
Ten years of work.
I'm like, are you serious?
I have to wait 10 years
to be what I want to be?
So anyways, fast
forwarding that Latin thing
that I have of survival
and fighting and finding
the thing that I
need to do, I found
my way of getting the courage to
actually apply and be like, OK,
maybe if I get denied
it will be fine.
At least I applied.
And low and behold,
everything worked out.
And I got into JPL.
And just to jump to the punch
line, there's no way on earth
that I ever thought that
this Latina girl who
didn't know any English, who
had no idea what she was going
to do with her life, will
end up as senior management
of the technical aspect
of a Rover on Mars.
So I want you guys to realize
that my story is something that
could be happening to
you, or to your parents,
or to your family.
Or to many of you
maybe you actually had
to save a lot of money to
even be here to hear us speak.
And the point is, it doesn't
matter where you're from
or what background you have.
Clearly, I was able to do it.
And if I can, so can you.
[APPLAUSE]
KARISHMA SHAH: So what
about for everyone else?
You're in tech, but did your
industry find your or did
you find your industry?
How did you develop
your passion?
Hillary, you said you
will always be a govie.
HILLARY HARTLEY: Yeah,
it's in my blood now.
A colleague on our team coined
the phrase, impact junkie.
That's really who
we are recruiting.
That's who comes
and serves with us.
So even if it's maybe adjacent
to government in the future,
I'll always be a govie.
KARISHMA SHAH: I love it.
Aniyia.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: Yeah, I would
say that for me, it really
just goes back to
my desire to create.
My background is
actually in music.
I'm a classically
trained singer.
I worked in nonprofit in
the arts for a little while.
And I started working in tech
because my husband's a software
engineer, and he got
recruited to work
at a company in San
Francisco, and we
decided-- we were in DC
at the time actually--
and decided we were just
going to quit our jobs,
and move to San Francisco.
And I kind of fell into tech.
And me starting
TINSEL was really
because I wanted to solve a
problem that I felt like I had,
which was digging
headphones out of the bottom
of my bag every day and
being so annoyed by that.
And untangling
them all the time,
and losing them,
and buying new ones.
But also feeling like the
options that were out there
didn't really suit me.
And I got that crazy
idea that maybe I
could be the one to make this
thing after I went and looked
to try to find it and buy it.
I thought it spoke to
the fact that no one was
trying to make the products
that I wanted to have.
And so that was a real
driver for me for sure.
KARISHMA SHAH: And you said when
you go to factories in China,
you're not amazed
that people aren't
making these products because
you're the only one there.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: Yeah,
that's definitely true.
I think that it also
does speak to when
we talk about representation
and diversity.
The lack of diversity
at the kinds
of companies that get to
make products like these.
When I go to China or even in
the parts around here, when
we get to see these
hardware companies
the stakeholders, the big
decision-makers in terms
of the direction of how
these products are made,
women aren't often with
the seat at the table.
And so it's not a big
shocker that the products
aren't made with us in mind.
I'd like to change that.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM HUNTER: Well, I went
to a Washington, DC at 18.
Born and raised in
Birmingham, Alabama.
My dad was an
HIV/AIDS researcher.
So I was doing AIDS marches at
eight years old in Birmingham,
Alabama, and became
just so conscious
of social justice issues
and the need for us
all to be active in our world.
And I was also a big
fan of The West Wing.
So I had it in my mind that if--
this is like dating me a bit.
But I wanted to be CJ Cregg.
I was like, I want to be
White House press secretary.
And at 18 I'm going to go to
George Washington University.
I'm going to get a degree
in Political Communications.
I'm going to intern at the DNC.
I'm going to work in the Senate.
I'm going to build my way
up to be at the White House.
And I started to do that.
And I got on this
ladder and I think
that the reason I
bring this up is
because I think there's
semblances between this
and what other women
can experience.
I got in this linear
ladder in which
I would go from this
internship to this job.
And I was going to start
climbing the ladder
to get to this point.
And I started to feel around
25 something didn't feel right.
I was like, do I really want to
be White House press secretary?
Is this how I'm going to really
make a change in the world?
And I started to try and
listen more to myself.
And also had to sort of
let go of some of the pride
or some of the expectations
that I let others put on me,
or that I would let
other people down
if I walked away
from this career
and started to
explore my passion.
And around 28 I
started to think,
I think I need to take
some time and figure out
what is my calling.
And so at 28 I quit my job,
sold everything, got a backpack,
and just hit the road.
And I just let myself
live and pick up
on what I really wanted.
And when I moved
to San Francisco,
I was going to be a consultant.
I was like, I'm going
to pivot, so to speak,
and take my communications
background from DC
and work with startups.
And it was tough.
I Airbnbing my
apartment to make rent.
I made a mixture of
lentil sausage and tomato
every week to eat at
like the lowest budget.
But I was rebuilding a
network, so yeah, it was tough.
I got off this ladder
and I started afresh.
But I had this
wealth of foundation,
wealth of information and
experience that I could apply.
And I worked hard and it was
tough, but eventually started
to make connections,
build community,
and now four years
later you know
I wasn't expecting
to be where I am.
But I think opening
myself up and not
having this tunnel vision
really made the world a lot
more colorful for me.
[APPLAUSE]
KARISHMA SHAH: And on the
topic of things being hard.
Aniyia, starting a
company is no easy feat.
Tell us about the challenges
in growing TINSEL.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: Yeah, yeah.
Everybody likes to
say hardware is hard.
I hate it when people say that.
Everything is hard.
In fact, I think I'm going to
answer that question in just
a second, but I kind
of want to, because I
feel like we're
already galvanizing
around this theme,
that it's hard,
but if you work hard
then you can get there.
And there's truth to that, but
it is also a lot more nuanced.
There is also
something to be said
for access and opportunities,
which I'm sure we'll
talk a little bit more about.
Hopefully we'll
have time for that.
But I would say
that I acknowledge
that I was in a really,
really fortunate position
when I started TINSEL.
So I would say that three
things made that possible.
I'm answering that question now.
One of them is that
I had been working
at a startup for a few years.
Started there because, like
I said, I quit my job in DC,
came to San Francisco,
and I was going
to actually start my own
thing like a Etsy shop,
actually, making wigs.
One of my hobbies
is making wigs.
And so I was like,
oh, this will be fun,
but I did I didn't
know anyone here.
So I was like, I also
do want to meet people.
And it ended up happening
that I got an opportunity
to work at the startup called
Voxer as an office manager.
And I was way
overqualified for the job,
but I was like, it's part time.
It's easy.
I'm going to meet new people.
The company sounds cool.
Sure.
And so very quickly
after I started there,
there was no lack of things
that they needed help with.
And I just would jump in
and start working on things,
and helping solve
problems, and made my way
through the organization.
So after about three
years of working there
I was running the
marketing team.
I was on the senior
team of the company.
And so that obviously was
recognized by the leadership
there.
When I had this
idea for TINSEL, I
was actually going and having
a conversation with the CEO.
And I was telling
him that I was going
to leave because I was
ready for a new challenge
and I didn't know what it was.
And I was like, I want
to give you a heads up.
I'm going to leave.
I'm not really sure what
I'm going to do next,
but I do have this
idea and I actually
wanted to ask you if you know
any industrial designers.
Because I have this
thing in my head.
I need someone that can
help me visually get what
I'm thinking out of my head.
And he made an
introduction to his friend.
His friend basically,
in that conversation,
told me if you want to build
hardware, you need money.
You can't make something out of
nothing with a physical thing.
And so he's just like,
you need to go back
and ask Tom for money.
He needs to invest in this.
And I'm like, OK.
All right.
And so I did actually
end up convincing
Tom to give me the
money to help see if it
had legs to get it started.
So that was the
first enabling thing.
I just happened to have
worked with someone
who had the resources
and believed in me.
I had that
relationship with them
that they would
take that bet on me.
The second thing was I mentioned
my husband's a software
engineer.
He worked at Yammer.
Yammer got acquired.
We got enough money
to have some savings
that I could take the
risk of quitting my job
and trying to do
this thing full-time.
And then I'd say the
third thing was just
a shit ton of creativity
and resourcefulness
that got me to where I am today.
And so going out and
needing more money.
Hardware is expensive.
And fundraising for it
is a huge challenge.
We actually did
do a crowdfunding
but even to get to the
crowdfunding campaign you need
so much money just to do
the product development,
to bring the team on, to
make sure you can actually
realize this thing.
And it was just a real struggle.
And so I feel like,
in my opinion,
I don't think that
investors in this area
really value hardware, or
fashion, or women-focused type
of companies.
But that's OK.
I think that you just have
to think about the fact
that there's many ways
you can skin a cat.
And that has kind of been a
theme of growing this company.
Is like trying to figure
out how you can do more
with less and other ways
that you can get around
a system that is
not made for you.
So that is what I
would also drive home
alongside the hardware.
Because yes, the shit is hard.
But you definitely
have to remember
that someone telling
you no isn't always
the end of the road.
You could try to find another
way to get in that door.
Go around like the back or sneak
in the window or something.
[APPLAUSE]
KARISHMA SHAH: So
clearly, adapting
to change is kind of a
theme that's evolving here.
Another theme that's
come out is your identity
is always evolving.
So how much is work a
part of your identity,
and what else makes
up your identity?
Hillary?
HILLARY HARTLEY:
Work has very much
become a part of my identity.
I think, probably similar
to some other startup
founders, 18F, we always
had a startup mentality.
We were the scrappy little
team inside a big bureaucracy,
and we always kind of thought
of ourselves as a startup.
And started with 10 people,
and quickly grew to 20, and 50,
and now we're 200 people
across the country from DC
to San Francisco.
And that has definitely
been my third kid.
I have two human kids
that I love very much.
But that team and that
effort has absolutely
been mine my third baby.
And it's a lot of work, but
it absolutely both fills me up
and takes away as well.
But it's absolutely sort of
become part of my identity.
And I think a huge part of
that has been being part
of the leadership of that team.
And also being kind of a leading
organization, a leading team,
something that's been in
the spotlight, because there
has been so much talk about
just the tech ecosystem
over the last four to eight
years at the federal level
between 18F, USDS, the
Presidential innovation
Fellowship.
And so I've taken
it very seriously
to be one of the folks that
gets to sit on this stage.
Whether it's here or
at any other conference
or any appearance.
And be my true self.
And be a woman that wants
to connect with folks.
Be a lesbian that wants
Be sort of just who I am.
And I think that that
has been supremely
important in terms of attracting
the similar kind of folk
to our team.
We do have a pretty vibrant
gay, and lesbian, and trans team
just in our small
200 person team.
And our female to male ratio
isn't what we want it to be,
but it's better than
the tech industry.
I think at one point
it was 30%-40%.
And the tech industry has
spent a billion dollars
on this diversity problem.
We're not figuring
our way out of it
by spending a lot of money.
It's just not happening.
[APPLAUSE]
Networks matter, access
matters, relationships matter,
mentor ships matter.
There are companies
that are starting
to figure out that magic mix
of data science, so some of it
is tech.
So that you can get into the
wells and get into the pools
that you want to get into, but
then mentorship and interview
style and all that
kind of stuff.
And so I think just that
piece of my identity I've
been really fortunate it's
been allowed to be out there
and flourish as well,
which has been--
KARISHMA SHAH: And
hopefully others
are able to follow a
similar path because you
were mentioning the last
thing Obama did, would you
like to share?
HILLARY HARTLEY: Oh, yes.
So I'm representing today.
This is the Presidential
Innovation Fellowship.
It's our little track jacket.
Everybody's got to have
a track jacket, you know.
Code for America
has a track jacket.
We were like, we
need track jackets.
So this is the PIF track jacket.
So yes, actually the
Presidential Innovation Fellows
have been a catalyst really.
They started in 2012 under the
Chief Technology Officer Todd
Park, and then Megan Smith
followed him, and really kept
the torch going.
And now through huge
bipartisan support,
literally everybody
voted for it.
It was called the TALENT Act.
I can't remember exactly
what that acronym is,
but it's the government.
But the TALENT Act has now made
the Presidential Innovation
Fellowship a permanent
part of government.
And it was literally
the last bill
that President Obama signed
as he was in the holding
room waiting to go out on stage
and pass the baton to President
Trump.
So we were very fortunate
to get that signed.
Yes, it's a big deal.
[APPLAUSE]
A lot of people going a heroic
last mile to get that signed,
but it is now part of
the legislative code,
and you can be a PIF too.
KARISHMA SHAH: We're
at about three minutes.
So anything for identity?
Otherwise there are a couple
of questions we can get to.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS:
Yeah I just want
to say that I think that
there are three things that
shape identity in my eyes.
The things that I do
as well as who I am.
I am a black woman.
There's no denying that.
I wear that in a
very visible way,
and it obviously
impacts the way that I
have interactions in the world.
And then the
choices that I make.
Including those to
become a mother.
I have a small child
and that has really
formed a new aspect of my
identity in the past year.
Handling, wrangling,
all of the things.
Being a mother,
building a company.
It's real.
[LAUGHTER]
KARISHMA SHAH: Diana?
DIANA TRUJILLO: I
think that I spend
a lot of my time
trying to figure out
how to find my identity.
And I think that I made
a couple of mistakes
that I wanted to
share with you guys.
Sometimes you think that
what you do is who you are,
and that has nothing
to do with it.
And I just had discovered
recently really
as I'm pregnant now and
I have a kid at home,
and my identity is everything.
Where I come from, what I
do, my family, how I behave,
what I think, how
I speak, my accent.
All of those things
is my identity.
And I think that
trying to separate
those things as you are coming
to the office, it's a bad idea.
Actually it's a much better
idea to bring all of that chaos
to the office.
Because that's when you
think, wait, I saw my kid
actually playing with that.
So we probably can do something
like this with the Rover
when it does this thing.
I literally have
done those things
where you could think there's
no way I could compare
my kids laughing about the
wind to try and to figure out
that's a bad idea to use
the arm when it's so windy.
And so I think that
that's my message.
My message with respect
to your question
is, don't separate your things.
Don't try to hide
certain things about you.
Just bring the whole
chaos to your office
and figure it out on the fly.
KIM HUNTER: Yeah
and I'll just add.
We interviewed a woman for Women
Catalysts a couple of weeks
ago.
Her name is Wendy Chen.
She was a record store
owner in San Francisco,
and then built the iTunes
Store from physical to digital.
And then she now is an
artist making knots.
And her main message
was, give yourself
permission to explore who you
are, and what your passions,
are and what you want to do.
Because bringing all of
yourself and allowing
yourself to do that is one
of the most important things
you can do.
KARISHMA SHAH: I love it.
OK, go ahead.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS:
I'm sorry, I just
want to say one
more thing before we
go is that to all the
women here in this room,
we were talking
about this backstage.
I think it deserves
to be said, which is
that you deserved to be here.
In fact, you deserve to be
in any room that you're in.
Do not let anyone question your
experience, your perspective,
the treasure that you
bring to any conversation.
You absolutely
deserve to be there.
Remember that.
[APPLAUSE]
KARISHMA SHAH: I'm
going to end with one
quick rapid-fire
question down the line.
15 seconds each.
What does your life look
like 10 years from now?
Are you in the same industry
or is it OK if passions change?
We're going to
start at that end.
And also just leave
us with a nugget
of knowledge about your world.
KIM HUNTER: Yeah,
well 10 years ago I
didn't think I'd
be sitting here.
10 years from now, I'm not
going make any promises.
I'm going to see where it goes.
I'm looking forward to
growing Women Catalysts.
Like Aclima is doing a lot
of exciting work right now.
Going to continue to build that.
And my nugget of advice would
be something that I actually
started to put into
practice just actually
in the last couple of months
was when you get wrapped up,
and you're on the passion track,
and you're on the chaos train,
I really encourage
you to try and develop
some time in the morning
to find some stillness
and listen to yourself.
Think about how you
want to approach
your day, how you
want to end it,
how you want to
interact with people.
I do it by throwing the i
Ching actually every morning.
Google it.
It's interesting.
It gives me that four minutes
before I start my day to tune
in.
And that makes me a tremendously
more effective leader,
and brings a lot more joy
and clarity to my life.
[APPLAUSE]
DIANA TRUJILLO: I think that
in 10 years from now for me
I have two goals.
One of them is I want to get
rid of that stereotype of what
Latina women should look
like and what we should do.
We should stay at
home, have babies.
That's not going to happen.
I am pregnant, but
that's not why.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think that I want
to fight that and in 10
years from now the
way that I feel
like I will be
fighting that is by,
like you said, having
representation.
I see myself being mission
manager of the mission that's
going to take humans to Mars.
And I hope to be in that room
and have some kids that say,
I want to be her.
[APPLAUSE]
I think that the
nugget of advice
that I have for you guys
is how I feel and I believe
the word confident means.
Sometimes I see the guys
walking in and they just say,
we're going to do this.
And it's like wait, you
haven't asked everyone else.
And I wonder sometimes
like, how do you
have that confidence,
walking in, and saying this,
and not even second guessing?
And I think that I don't
believe that that is confidence,
actually.
I think that the word confidence
is the ability of you keeping
a positive mind that
you're going to figure out
what's going to happen.
It's not about walking in
and dominating the room.
It's about walking in and
knowing I can do that,
and I'm going to figure out
even if I don't know how.
KARISHMA SHAH: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: I would
say that I definitely
want to continue the
proliferation of these really
beautiful hardware fem tech
things out in the world.
But alongside that it's also
really, really important to me
that I do my part in allowing
opportunities for more women
and people of color to be
able to start businesses
and bring their ideas to life.
I think that the bar
is really, really high
in terms of being able to take
that risk and take that leap.
And I really want to make
it more possible for people
like me to pursue
something that they really
should have the chance to do.
[APPLAUSE]
HILLARY HARTLEY: I'm
just going to be honest
and say, I have no idea.
My oldest kid is 7, so he'll
be 17 about to graduate,
go to college.
So that-- even just thinking
about that freaks me out.
So I really don't know.
Although what I
do hope is that I
continue to be in a
position to essentially
both make an impact
on the world,
but also make an
impact on individuals.
Not just through the
services or whatever
that my team might be
delivering at any given moment,
but by nurturing folks into
places that they want to be.
Two nuggets of wisdom.
One, in terms of a mentor,
someone I look up to.
She's on my mind
because I've seen
her a couple of times
in the last week,
but just last night I was
honored to go and sit at a gala
where Megan Smith was awarded.
And Megan was here at
Google, and then she
was the third Chief Technology
Officer of the United States.
And the thing that I think
I most admire about her,
and the thing that I think
I want to bring to myself,
and that I've noticed about
how I start to interact just
both with my team
and with the world,
is that Megan will bring anybody
into the room where it happens.
She makes you feel
like you're important
and that you belong there.
And I think that
is so important.
And if you're
looking for a mentor,
if you're looking for those
experiences, I know it's hard
and imposter syndrome
is absolutely real,
I am a living proof.
But if you can bring
up the courage to ask,
I guarantee you
someone will say yes.
KARISHMA SHAH: Amazing.
So to finding our way together.
Let's help each other out.
Let's give it up for these
phenomenal women again.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]